SAMI ZUHURUDDIN:
Thank you for coming.
My name is Sami Zuhuruddin.
I am a Solutions Architect
on the Google Cloud team.
Just a quick show
of hands, who here--
this talk is mainly geared
towards the decisionmakers--
CEOs, leaders, IT execs.
Who here is here because
they are in that capacity?
OK, great.
Who's here because the
ML session was full?
That's why I'm here.
All right, so, now that we
know each other so well--
you know about me,
I know about you--
I'd like to admit
something here right
at the outset, which
is fine once you
know a group of people.
So I'd like to admit
that about 10 years ago I
worked for a startup.
That's not what
I'm here to admit.
Who hasn't worked for a startup?
That's a more relevant
question nowadays.
Who hasn't worked for a startup?
OK, cool, about five of you.
But, anyways, I had a serious
problem about 10 years ago
working for a startup.
I used to rack
and stack servers.
It went part and parcel
with the job back then.
It was satisfying.
You'd look at servers,
you'd stack them,
or you'd rack and stack them,
you'd turn around, it's done.
Of course, when I racked
and stacked servers,
they did not look this good.
But like what happens with
every startup, we got bought.
That's pretty much what
happens with every startup--
most of them.
A couple of them
don't get bought.
But things calmed down
and I had a chance
to reflect in a
new organization.
Things calmed down.
In any startup, things
are very chaotic,
but things calmed down.
You look at the patterns
you've been engaging on
and decide what's next.
How do you optimize?
How do you clean things up?
There's a lot of technical debt.
And the idea of
racking servers, I
was like there has
to be a better way.
And, of course, what was coming
and prevailing on the scene
at the time was you can get
away from racking and stacking
servers by interacting
with an API.
And I thought that
was pretty cool stuff.
As much as I enjoyed racking and
stacking servers and deploying
things by hand, nothing
was quite as easy
as issuing a command, and
then all of a sudden you
have resources at your disposal.
So things winded down
for me in terms of what
I was doing as an IT leader.
And I was like, you know what?
I think this cloud
thing is pretty cool.
I'm going to go and--
I saw a job description,
a solution architect.
What is this?
You go talk to customers.
That sounds great.
You tell them the
cloud is great.
I'm like, I can do that.
And I was like,
yeah, that's easy.
I mean, it's like
a total easy sale.
So I thought that'd be great.
I'd talk to people like myself
and I'll spread the word.
And what I found, of
course, was that as soon
as I started having
conversations,
a lot of the IT executives
are like not so fast.
You don't know anything.
And what I found is it turns
out that IT leadership is just
spread across a huge spectrum.
And they have really
varied reactions
to the idea of
going to the cloud.
And generally, time has
caused this to shift over.
A few years ago, most
of the conversations
are about awareness, and what's
possible, and stuff like that.
Now it's generally about
strategy, execution, costs,
picking a cloud, picking
a technology that you
can use to move to the cloud.
It's about cloud strategy.
Everybody today has
a cloud strategy,
except for those who don't.
But they all say they
have a cloud strategy.
It's just some of them are
in research and some of them
are not.
But it's not enough
to simply say, hey,
we're going to
move to the cloud.
That's necessary,
but not sufficient.
And that's rightfully so.
As you move towards a CIO
organization, there's sort of--
they're dealing with a lot.
There's security breaches, and
capex, and how to train folks.
And so, it's rightfully
cautious and concerned.
There's a lot at stake.
And this is the way it's
come together for me.
This is my grouping.
This is loosely resembling
the "Crossing the Chasm"
from Geoffrey Moore.
But generally what
I find is there's
sort of this huge break on
this spectrum, which is folks
that are at that end of it.
They haven't touched cloud
much, and it takes a lot
to get them off that path.
And then there's some
that warm up to your idea,
and they'll say, oh,
we'll do dev and test.
Why?
Because that's kind
of a throw away--
or it's an easy one to look at.
But the big moment is when you
do that first production app.
I find that that's
generally the first time
that the light bulbs
go off to where
this is something that's real.
Usually, I find when
folks cross that chasm,
things accelerate
very, very fast.
And you start talking
about hybrid cloud.
We want to bridge
environments together.
networks together.
We want cloud
environment to look
like the on-prem environment.
And the evolution
of that is folks
say, OK, we're going to exit.
We're going to exit on-prem.
We're going to have a three year
strategy, a five year strategy
to be all inside the cloud.
And there's so many of
these success stories.
I call them success stories.
I don't know if hardware vendors
call them success stories,
but I call them success stories.
And then there's cloud native.
Cloud native is this term that
means that, you know what?
You're looking at APIs, and
you're looking at technologies
and saying how do we
actually build and rebuild
our applications and redesign
them to take advantage
of these platforms?
And so, for someone
in my position,
it makes a lot of sense
to try to interpret
the signals that you hear from
folks across that spectrum.
And so, today's talk is
generally about cloud adoption,
but it's specifically
about Google Cloud.
And it's a collection of
feedback that I've seen.
It's a collection of direct
feedback from customers
and lessons learned.
Some of the customers
are actually here.
And so, I tried to make the
talk divided in two parts.
One of it is just
observations I see
about what makes cloud
endeavors very successful inside
of customer organizations.
And the other is about what
folks on top of Google Cloud
have told me made a
difference to their journey.
And so, I try to interpret
the signals I get,
because I'd like
to figure out where
folks are on that spectrum.
And this is a very
telling signal
that someone's on the very
early part of the spectrum.
I, myself, used to say this.
This is a very kind
of safety setting.
But essentially, it's a--
hey, nobody ever got
fired for, and then you
pick your favorite vendor.
And it's sort of like a--
it's a very safe place,
but it tells me where
somebody is on the spectrum
and what kind of discussions are
going to be relevant to them.
And I, myself-- like I said--
have said this in the
past, maybe 10 years ago.
But it tells me that we need to
challenge conventional wisdom.
I apologize here.
Sorry about that.
The irony is I know CEOs
who used to say this.
And by the time they
realized that this
was more prohibitive than
it wasn't prohibitive,
it was too late for them
or their organizations,
and it required drastic
change to move out of it.
This is another signal.
This is another signal,
a different kind
of CIO, a different
kind of IT executive
where they sort of get it.
They sort of know.
Eventually, they can see
that the end of this horizon
is to end up on the
other side of it.
And this is usually
a great indicator,
a great signal that they're
looking at their environment
very differently.
They're like, the folks I
have today or the skills
that I have today
aren't quite going
to align with that
cloud journey.
We need to rethink this.
We need to foster new skills.
And so, it tells
me that they see
that that's the end
of the destination,
but they're not really
sure how to incubate that.
What I find interesting about
that is the skills like--
OK, networking is still a skill.
Folks that know
networking are still
required in a cloud
environment, but the way
they're going to do networking
changes dramatically.
And so, what I advocate is
if somebody knows networking,
that's 100% applicable.
If somebody knows
application development,
that's 100% applicable.
But what we need to do is
educate on the fact of--
or train on the
fact of how do you
use API-driven infrastructure if
folks haven't used code before,
if folks haven't used
automation tools.
These are the things
we need to bolster on.
But the fundamental
concepts about how
do you secure an environment,
how networking works,
how application development
works, how storage works,
these things don't
really change.
Regardless of which side
of the spectrum you're on,
by and large, this is the
first thing that comes out.
We don't want to lock-in.
And it's not really an
objection about moving forward.
Even if somebody
has decided going
cloud is completely the way
to go, lock-in is a huge fear.
And the reality is, there's
two kinds of lock-in.
This is the way I've broken
down this discussion.
It's what makes sense to me, and
I think it comes across well.
There's hard lock-in.
Hard lock-in is
the kind of lock-in
where you're in an environment,
you're in a contract,
and there's pain
or financial waste
for backtracking or ceasing
that use of that contract.
And so, you're pretty
much locked-in.
You're like, you know what?
We signed this.
We're committed for
the next three years
to use this environment,
use this technology.
And so, it has this
negative connotation to it.
In reality, these
are something else
that I think that we
don't pay attention to.
There's something
called soft lock-in.
Soft lock-in, to me, is
much, much more relevant.
Soft lock-in is
all the decisions
you make above the hardware.
So picking a database,
picking an application stack,
picking an application framework
has a much longer tail from a--
has a much longer tail, from
an environment perspective,
than the hard lock-in.
And what I mean by
that is you don't
tend to change your
database on a dime.
You don't tend to change your
application stack on a dime.
And so, what you want
to do is spend time
figuring out how to make
this soft lock-in choice
in a way that gives you
the most flexibility.
And this is what's going
to sound paradoxical
is, how do you make a soft
lock-in choice that makes sure
that you're open to
a lot of choices?
And the way to do that is
to pick open standards--
open standards, open
APIs, open source.
And this is why Google
spends a lot of time
in this dimension around that.
And it's going to
seem paradoxical,
but if you make the right
soft lock-in choices,
it really gives you
a lot of leverage
to avoid getting stuck in
a hard lock-in situation.
And we'll talk more
about that in the future.
And the best way to
do this, the best way
to pick a soft lock-in
option is to look
at where the trajectory
is of a certain technology
in open source frameworks
that are being released.
Figure out where
are they going, do
they align with the
development objectives we have?
And if we choose
those, does it give us
the most flexibility to
avoid being hard locked
in to an environment?
So they're intertwined,
but I often
find that folks just get
stuck on the hard lock-in when
they just want a
bunch of parachutes
to get out of an environment.
And that sometimes
is a hindrance,
because you're spending
more time figuring out
how to make sure you're not
locked in to an environment
than figuring out how
to make choices that
allow you to build your stack.
At the end of the day, we
have to build software.
So what I'd like to do instead
is to step back and say,
what kind of
organization are you?
That's a far more
relevant conversation.
If we get stuck down into
making exact technical choices,
then I feel like we dive
into the weeds too fast.
Now, I like ask are
you a product company,
are you a service company,
are you a data company?
And not focusing on what
kind of business you are
is missing the
forest for the trees.
And the best
conversations are the ones
that get down into what
kind of company are you,
what do you want to do?
And then it becomes clear
what is the purpose of your IT
organization.
When it becomes clear what the
purpose of your IT organization
is, to me, I like having
this revelation moment.
The commonality in all of those
situations is it's software.
Your IT organization
is basically
helping enable software.
And that software could
be driving your business.
That software could be
the crux of your business.
It could be the product
of your business.
It could be making what you
produce as a company software
better.
There isn't anything in
terms of an IT organization
that isn't made better
by better software that's
produced faster-- not
just faster software.
That's just better
software, but software
that you can produce
faster at a higher quality.
And that's why it's
relevant to be here today.
If this was a manufacturing
conference and you
were a medical
device manufacturer,
you'd be talking about making
the manufacturing process more
efficient, because that's
critical to your business.
But when you're at a technical
conference like this,
and when you're figuring out
what technologies to use,
what cloud to use,
obviously, it's
about those
technologies in helping
you make better software.
And so, as it turns out,
Google has a little bit
of experience with software.
This was our original mission.
And from the beginning, Google
has been about, essentially,
harnessing the world's data,
making it globally, universally
accessible and meaningful.
And to do that, you have to
learn a lot about dealing
with data at scale.
And we've done a lot
of things to figure out
how to deal with data at scale.
And the slides keep
going off sync.
Sorry.
And that's resulted in two
aspects of Google's forte.
Google has technical leadership
that we'll talk about
and infrastructure leadership.
And if we didn't develop new
mechanisms and techniques
for dealing with
data at scale, they
wouldn't have led to the
revelations, and research,
and infrastructure that we
have in order to power that.
This is an incredible
feat, to be
able to deal with
data at the volume
where you can be
sitting on your phone
right here-- as a great
number of you are--
and surfing your mail.
That's something
that we have had
to break the mold of what was
conventionally possible before.
But when we say Google
is a technical leader
or an infrastructure
leader, that's
not meant to be an
exclusionary term.
Google, in fact,
puts out thousands
of papers of research.
This is an example of--
you can go to this right now.
I mean, if you want
to, literally right now
you could go to this.
And papers have come out
on GFS, HDFS, MapReduce.
And that is directly,
essentially,
the impetus behind Hadoop.
Bigtable is the
impetus behind HBase--
Dremel is the inspiration
behind Apache Drill,
Borg, and so on and so forth.
And so, from
Google's perspective,
yes, we essentially have had
to solve all these problems.
We've put all
these problems out.
We put the solutions of these
problems out on the internet.
So when I talked earlier
about open standards
and open interfaces,
we've done a lot
to make sure that,
as a community,
you're enabled with
the same assets.
And they've resulted in some of
the projects that have affected
how data is managed today.
And I don't where the
data community would
be without things like Hadoop.
A second token of
that is open source.
So when I talked
about research, these
are things that we put
out in the form of papers.
But open source, these
are direct projects
that we're, essentially,
grooming, and curating,
and producing to the community.
And technologies like Go, and
Angular, and TensorFlow, these
are technologies that are
part of infrastructure stacks
and software development
stacks that you're
using today, currently.
And so, when I talk
about our research
and I talk about
our open source,
this is an example of what I
deem the technical leadership,
is that Google is pushing the
bounds to solve our mission,
to bring that
mission to reality.
We're pushing the
bounds of what's
possible with data at
scale, and we're simply
sharing that with the world.
We're putting that out there.
But our technical leadership
doesn't stand on its own.
So it takes an enormous
amount of infrastructure,
in the form of data centers,
and compute, and storage,
and network.
It takes a tremendous amount
of technical infrastructure
to support, essentially, the
open source or the published
software that I've talked about.
And so, that becomes the other
pillar of the Google dynamic.
It's what we put out in terms
of our thought leadership
and what we put out in terms of
our infrastructure leadership.
And I sort of mentioned this
as a buildup to the fact
that Google makes sure--
or the way we work
internally-- we
try to make sure that developers
are enabled and empowered.
We don't want developers to deal
with very low level operations.
We don't want developers to
have to think about logging
into servers.
We want developers to have as
little friction as they can,
because we want them to make
better software, faster.
And so, we've figured out
how to abstract hardware,
like the idea of
notion of servers,
and where you should
store data, and where
you should backup
things, and how
networks should be structured.
We've abstracted all that
away so the developers
can have a very fast
clip of moving forward.
And if they can
have a faster clip,
they can improve software
development, times, quality,
and make it faster.
So why do I spend
so much time here?
This wasn't meant
to be a sales pitch,
but I want you to understand
where Google is coming.
Wayne Gretzky says skate
to where the puck is going.
That was echoed probably about
1,200 times this morning.
But it's an important
notion to think
about is that Google thinks
about these problems,
because it's entirely
relevant to its own mission.
And it makes sure
that the community--
it's not an exclusionary thing.
It makes sure that
the community is
able to take advantage of that.
And it's entirely
relevant to you
being here for Google
Cloud, because if you
put those two aspects together--
our technical leadership
and our infrastructure
leadership--
and you put those as
inputs, the output of that
is Google Cloud Platform.
The very same things that I've
talked about in our research,
in our open source, and what
was talked about all morning
is what is put
into Google Cloud.
So not only is it
something that you
can go and download,
and figure out--
download the research papers
and download the open source,
but it's now served up in a way
that's very easily consumable.
It's very curated.
And that same technical
infrastructure
that the $27 billion
number was about that's
created and crafted
around the world,
that's also served up to you.
What does Google Cloud
Platform look right now?
This is the statutory
slide of our services.
So this list keeps
getting bigger.
There was items
announced this morning.
And if you compare
it to a year ago,
two years ago, this is starting
to get very, very fleshed out.
It's not going to fit on
one slide by next year.
And this is important,
because I think
some folks have a
conception of where Google
is in the marketplace, where it
is from a services perspective.
And I like to make sure
that folks know that--
maybe we're not doing the
best job of advocating it--
but this list is directly
informed by our research,
the products we run
internally, and how they've
been brought forward to
things as simple as compute,
that everybody knows, but
also things like data flow
that is directly based
on internal technologies
that we've externalized.
So I'd like to get to
the practical side.
So I've given you
this background
on how to think about
lock-in, and where Google
is coming from with the
research it produces,
and how we look to our technical
leadership and our thought
leadership.
But now I'd like to move
to the technical side
of the talk, which is this
is all feedback I've gotten
from IT executives,
from IT leaders
as they've moved to
the Google Cloud.
Some of them are
not on Google Cloud,
but this is the
feedback I've gotten.
And I bucketed it into
these five general areas
that I feel cause
friction, or our customers
feel have caused friction,
or that, conversely,
if they've gotten
them right, it's
made a much more
pleasant journey
to go into Google Cloud.
So I'd like to go through
each one of these things
and highlight just a few items.
There's deep dive talks
on every single one
of these areas in
the other talks
that are going on over
the next three days.
But if I can highlight
a few of the things
that I think made
a difference, I
think that will make your
overall experience on coming
to Google Cloud better.
Go back one, please.
So economics-- I hear this a
lot, is there's this unknown.
When you buy a server,
you know upfront how much
it's going to cost.
When you do lock-in into
some of these scenarios,
it's kind of
refreshing, because you
know exactly how
much the outlay is,
and how much the support
contract is going to be.
And then there's all
sorts of cloud studies
that say this cloud is
cheaper, that cloud is cheaper.
And if I was to put up
a big slide that said
Google Cloud is cheaper--
which we've done--
I think the gut reaction is,
well, how do you gauge that?
How do you assess that?
How do I, as an IT
leader, assess that?
How do I pass that down?
It's just some internal
assessment that you guys have.
So I say trust us.
I'm a believable guy.
But rather, what I
think is more useful
is to highlight the fact that
this is completely transparent.
You can go to three
options that I highlight.
One is a pricing calculator.
I cringe when I
hear somebody say,
well, we think the costs are
going to run away from us.
We think that this is going
to be way more expensive.
You're hiding something.
I've read this horror
story about a customer who
had runaway costs
with everything
that they put up in the cloud.
I don't understand
how that's possible,
because you could plug
in every single thing
into our calculator.
And it's really because
you can do it by workload.
You can say how many
VMs is it expected
to take, how much bandwidth
is it going to take,
how much storage do I need?
And that becomes really handy
because, number one, you
get to highlight how much the
savings are, but number two,
it's savable.
So you can share that
around as an artifact
and send that to finance,
and managers, et cetera,
and get budget
approval that way.
But it puts the onus
on you to decide
if it's a worthwhile venture
or how much savings there is.
There is all kinds of
internal aspects as well.
So there's a pricing calculator,
there's a pricing page,
and there's a TCO calculator.
We realize that's a very,
very common activity
is for you to say how do you
stack up against X, Y, Z.
And so, our TCO calculator
goes, basically, and says,
here's a particular
given workload
that's on our
platform, and here's
what it's currently running
on another platform.
And so, we try to demystify
that process as much as we can.
There's some interesting
aspects to the way we do--
to the way we
manage our pricing.
Number one is that
VMs are per minute,
after a minimum of 10 minutes.
And you're just
charged per minute.
So what that does is
it gets you very, very
close to the grain of how
you're consuming a service.
There's rightsizing VMs, so
you can customize the VM size
to the exact amount of memory
and CPU that you want to use.
And we typically see
a tremendous amount
of savings when folks
optimize the heck out
of how they're
using Google Cloud.
You can see upwards of over 50%.
Again, if I put up
a slide with 50%,
I think that meets with
a lot of skepticism.
So instead, price it out.
Use things like
per minute billing,
use things like
preemptible VMs that I'll
talk about in a second.
Preemptible VMs--
I'll highlight that.
So I talked about per minute
and I talked about other things.
Preemptible VMs--
essentially this
means that you can spin up a VM.
We could take it away
with any time within-- you
get it for up to 24 hours.
But as long as it
keeps running, you're
getting that VM on upwards
of about an 80% discount.
So if you have things like
batch processing, things
that run in the background,
then that's fixed.
You just get an 80% discount for
as long as that VM is running.
Again, it's still
per minute billing.
And then what's not shown here
is that the pricing is always
trending downwards.
This is another one that I
hear from a lot of pricing
and pricing discussions.
And we don't
believe in soft ROI,
is usually the way
that I hear that back.
And I was like, well,
did you say that or did
your finance guy say that--
or did your finance person
say that, I should say.
And I get it.
It's much easier to
deal with hard ROI.
If I purchase A
and I purchase B,
I just want to know
what the delta is.
But that is such a disservice,
because of the fact of--
how do you account for the
fact that if your team can
essentially work twice as fast,
or if you can produce software
with half the number
of participants?
These things make
a big difference.
I mean, I kind of
liken it to the fact
that why do companies
acquire other companies?
They acquire other
companies usually because
of market reach, et cetera.
But a lot of times it's because,
well, that small startup
is like two years ahead
of us in this space.
So if you buy them, it
works out better for us,
because we'll get a jumpstart
into that marketplace
by two years.
We'll acquire all
those engineers.
So we make all kinds of
decisions in our business
to accelerate the
pace of business.
And on the outright, I think
that you could turn around
and measure all those things.
But when it comes to
cloud, for some reason,
those economics are hard
to instill in people.
But what I would say is
to do yourself justice,
look at the software ROI factor.
There's a lot of sort of--
at this point, there's a
lot of data and collateral
about just how much faster folks
can work in a cloud environment
with open APIs, and open
source, et cetera than they
can in a non-cloud environment.
Or what happens if a
developer can work twice as
fast with an easier tool set?
If you don't measure
that, I think
it becomes hard to
see the cloud value.
If you just start looking
at pure economics--
economics are better, but they
just look a whole lot better
when you make sure
that you factor
in exactly how much better
your teams are operating.
This is how I see things going
from a consumption perspective,
is that if you think
about buying a server
and racking and stacking it,
you're akin to owning it.
If you think about locking
into a one year agreement
to use a particular VM for
a certain amount of time--
[INAUDIBLE] or something
like that-- that's
kind of akin to renting it.
You're paying a fixed amount
for a large block of time.
What's happening now-- and we
see this just in every single
product--
is that the grain is becoming
as small as it can be.
So I talked about
our VM pricing.
Our VM pricing is per minute.
That's close to as close to
the grain as you can get,
in terms of consuming that, but
per the gigabyte, per the API
call.
There's a number of
companies right now
who have found a
whole new economy
in externalizing their APIs.
Google has recently acquired
a company called Apigee.
And that was the entire
mode of that company
was helping
companies externalize
their APIs for some
sort of consumption,
in many cases around
monetary consumption.
And so, as an IT
leader or somebody
who is trying to consume
services, what this should do
is it should make you ask
the question as you're
consuming a service.
Well, are we consuming
it, or does it
look more like we're renting it,
or in fact, does it look more
like we're buying
it, because we're
going to be stuck with
this thing for three years?
In a perfect world,
you could consume,
which basically
means you just pay
per the metered use
of that service,
pretty much on the scale of
what the best pricing is.
That's the win-win arrangement.
And so, as you're looking
to how you consume,
or how you acquire IT services--
including a cloud environment
for each of the dimensions that
you're acquiring-- think about,
well, is there a
consumption-based model
for what I'm doing
so that I don't
have to get stuck
into something that
looks like a lock-in
or a longer term?
There are many of
the things we do
on top of Google Cloud that
actually help that consumption
model.
There's an interesting trend.
I'll mention it and
I'll highlight it later,
but when a VM can spin
up in roughly a minute--
that's about the time it
takes for our VMs to spin up,
and we're charged per minute.
It makes all kinds of patterns--
all kinds of new
patterns possible.
So if anybody here
has been-- who's
here managed a
Hadoop cluster or has
had to have a Hadoop cluster
in their environment?
And so, you think about
managing a Hadoop cluster,
and it's like this monolithic
ad server, ad server, ad server.
And you're growing
this HDFS environment,
or you're doing it to
increase your worker
capability, or your
mapper capability,
or your storage capability.
But if we have VMs that
can spin up in 90 seconds
or spin up in 60
seconds, then we've
turned that model on its head.
We have a great blog
post that came out
that basically showed how
customers were, essentially,
saying, well, I have
got this batch of data
and I need to run a job on it.
I actually spin up
a cluster to run
against the data,
output a report,
and then I tear
down the cluster.
And because I'm
paying by the minute,
that's a pretty easy
operation to accommodate.
I'll talk about that
again in a second.
Security-- this, by and large,
it becomes the sticky point,
because this is where compliance
officer starts to get involved,
and [INAUDIBLE] starts get
involved, and IT starts--
just let it go.
Just let it go.
We don't want you
to let anything go.
There's a lot of
security framework
built into the platform.
I think that not hitting this
head-on in your discussions--
hit it head-on with Google, as
you engage with Google head-on.
But it's absolutely something
you'll want to engage on.
So right now at Google, there
are something like over 600
dedicated security engineers.
These are folks that
actually deal day
in and day out with security.
That research link that
I sent in the beginning,
that research link--
we have something
like 160 publications
on just security things
that have been adopted
by other companies.
Companies have been formed
by some of the research
that we put out.
But we've made steps
to, essentially,
make sure that you can
trust us but verify.
The medium, the language
we use to disseminate
how we adhere to a--
how we adhere to a
certain security bar
is by means of certifications
and attestations.
And so, those are the
certifications and attestations
that we have.
But that's not enough.
That's the trust but verify.
It means that somebody else
has come into our environment,
verified everything we
had, and made it externally
digestible by yourselves.
We also have become
very prescriptive,
and prescriptive in
the sense that we
put out a security white paper.
And we tell you, essentially,
from an application
perspective, how do you build
an application securely?
These are white papers that are
available currently, right now.
And the important thing
to realize there is it's,
obviously, when we talk
about a secure platform,
we both have skin in the game.
Google is making sure that,
essentially, all the attack
vectors that fall
within the providers--
with us, as a cloud provider
spectrum, are taken care of.
But that doesn't stop you from
leaving SSH open to the world
and putting your private
key in a public bucket.
If you don't believe
mean, just Google that.
You'll see people do
things like that--
or leaving a bucket wide
open and it's your backups.
So with great power
comes great stupidity.
Obviously, we want to
make sure that you're
using the right controls.
But the underlying is there is--
what is the inherent security.
There's no reason for you
to question that or wonder
if it exists.
We say it's simply check
out the attestations.
We can send you these, and
check out the white papers.
How do I know Google's not
doing funny things with my data?
So, by default,
everything is encrypted.
Everything is
encrypted in motion
and everything's
encrypted at rest.
This is the encryption at rest.
There's a white paper
there at the bottom that
goes into it in far more
detail, but nothing is ever
written inside a Google
platform that's not encrypted.
We do some unique things,
though, on top of that.
One is you get to pick where you
want to be on this continuum.
If you want it fully managed,
it means we just encrypt.
There's nothing we write of
your data that's not encrypted.
But we also have
another option, which
is essentially you can
hold the keys of how
your data is encrypted.
That takes two flavors.
That's a flavor where we manage
the apparatus, the cloud--
essentially, the cloud
service that holds the keys,
but it's your--
you dictate what
applications and what
systems can retrieve keys out.
That's a service we
have called Cloud KMS.
And we do something
unique here, which
is customer supplied
encryption keys.
And what this means is this is
your own key management system,
where you can bring your keys
into Google's environment,
and your data will be
encrypted with your keys.
And, essentially, what
that means is that when--
the key, as it's
transmitted to us,
will be used for decryption
and encryption operations,
but we never store
the key on disk.
It's only used in memory, and
you supply it in operations
that you need to use
encrypted data on.
And that applies currently to
our VMs and our cloud storage.
The important
thing to realize is
when you're at
the fully managed,
there's sort of an
efficiency-- or I
would say there's a
trade-off of efficiency.
As you move towards the customer
supplied keys, obviously,
there's-- it implies a higher
number of operations that are
going to be having to take
place between a customer
and the environment.
So if you're at the
fully managed side that's
native to the
platform, your data
is always written and encrypted.
If you're on the other
side of the spectrum,
then there's a higher
number of operations
for these decrypt
things that take on.
But the important
thing is you can
feel very comfortable that
your data is never unencrypted.
And if you ever said
I wanted-- like, hey,
this is really,
really sensitive data.
I never want there to be
a possibility of looking
at it without my involvement.
In fact, I don't even want
the keys inside of Google.
We give you that flexibility.
I think that's something
unique to us right now.
Similarly, there's never
a mystery of who did what.
I think this is a
fear or phobia of who
opened my environment, who
opened my firewall, who
exported my data.
All that stuff is
available in audit logs.
This is pretty standard stuff.
This is available to you
to see on our audit logs.
It's available for you to stream
out and feed it into your sim
system, to feed it
to Splunk, to feed
it any number of
downstream systems.
So we don't make it
a mystery as to who's
done what on your environment.
This is a fun one.
Security keys-- how many
people have used security keys?
Cool.
Do all you people
work for Google?
No?
So this is really
something I found fun.
I joined Google, and I was
told, hey, we don't have VPN.
I was like, yes, no
more working from home.
And they're like, that's
not what it means.
We just don't have
VPN within Google.
We use different
kind of mechanisms.
We assume.
We don't make any
assumptions about open trust,
and open networks,
and things like that.
We don't have this hard,
outer candy shell model.
We essentially assert identity
and encryption and security
at every single interaction
and every single call.
And this is one of them.
So it hinges on identity.
Identity is key.
Identity is, essentially,
at a fundamental level,
how you endorse somebody
within your environment
to do something inside of
the Google Cloud environment.
And so, we basically put
identity on a pedestal.
It's very important to us for
that not to get screwed up.
So Google came up with
a standard called UTF.
That's also on the
research paper,
and we've externalized it now.
It's taken up by something
called the FIDO Alliance.
And so, these keys
are made by folks
that implement that standard.
But this is unphishable--
phishing resistant.
I apologize--
This is your best bet for
avoiding network-based vector
attacks.
So what that means is if
you have a laptop right now
and somebody is looking
over your shoulder,
and they've discovered
your username and password,
and they take your
laptop, and it has a key,
you're out of luck.
That's bad.
But somebody in the middle--
this is the more prevalent case
is you're being phished.
Somebody sends you a link,
an email that looks legit.
You click on it.
It's very
sophisticated nowadays,
and you're duped into
giving away your username
and password, heaven forbid.
So when an attacker
has that, they're
going to turn around and
try to use those credentials
immediately on
whatever source system
they fooled you into using.
And so, folks said,
OK, you know what?
We'll do this one-time
password thing
where we'll send a code to your
phone, or a six digit rotating
code, or a one-time password,
and that will protect you.
If somebody's fooled you
into sending your username
and password, they're fooling
you into sending that, too.
So the idea is that this--
because you are in a position
to give away those credentials.
You can say, oh, it's one,
two, three, four, five, six.
Here, one, two,
three, four, five six.
Thank you very much.
I'll turn around and
break into your account.
This is outside your scope
of knowing what's going on.
These keys get
enrolled in Google.
And, essentially, for those of
you who are familiar with SSH,
this is equivalent to
what happens with SSH.
There is two halves
of a key pair
that no human can
cryptographically
get in the middle of it.
So if you get an assertion
back from whatever
website and your
security goes, that
doesn't match my
signature, then you
know that basically you're not
talking to the source you've
enrolled it to.
Conversely, if somebody tries
to break into your account,
because they have your
user name and password,
and they just somehow
figure out they're
going to spoof this
and send something
random, the same thing.
They're going to be like, that
doesn't match the challenge
phrase of what was enrolled.
So we found this to be, again,
one of the most effective ways.
And the other thing is, we found
that it takes how many seconds
to break out the one-time
password, log into your phone,
extract those keys,
and send them over.
You just touch this.
That's all it takes.
It takes a human touch,
because if it didn't require
a human intervention,
then you can essentially
write something browser-based
that could spoof a touch.
So this requires a
physical human touch.
It's really cool.
That's why I spent a
little bit of time on it.
I think even if, for
nothing else, spend the $10
and get this.
On to networking and operations.
Identity-- so piggybacking
on how critical identity is
to get right, and making sure
nobody breaks the identity,
and nobody falsely claims
who they are, in order
to do anything inside of the
Google Cloud environment,
we need to assert your identity.
And so, we need to
know who you are.
And so, we have a couple
of ways to do that.
So a big tip here that I've
heard from a lot of customers--
and we've made
this pretty easy--
is use something called
our directory sync,
which can take your
directory and replicate that
into your G Suite instance.
And so, that way we know
about users, and groups,
and attributes.
Passwords don't get synced.
Passwords you still have to
create at a Google level.
But this way, if somebody
leaves your environment,
directory sync will
trigger and remove them.
If you add somebody to a group,
those groups can be used.
We can do SSL back to
your-- we, essentially,
say I'm going to federate back
to some other authentication
system, whether using a
third party hosted version
or on prem.
So you can say, OK, when
somebody needs to authenticate,
I want that to come
all the way back home.
I don't want that to
be inside of Google--
or either way.
We also give you
something is that once you
have authenticated within
the browser experience
when you log into Google
Cloud, we give you something
called Google Cloud Shell.
And so, it's essentially a
browser-based SSH experience
that once you've established
your identity and you assert
that I'm so-and-so,
and you've done your--
if you have it,
your security key,
you don't have to
rely on something
as static as opening a port
and opening an IP address.
We can, essentially, say now
that we know who you are,
we'll give you a
console that will
help you drive your interactions
with the cloud environment,
rather than having to set
up all your tools on prem
and figure that out.
So it's called Cloud Shell.
I'll let you check that out.
This is how we organize
your cloud environment.
The top level are something
called an organization node.
So within, say, a lot
of alternate providers,
it's very easy to lose track
of what accounts I have.
That's a big concern
that I've heard
from a number of customers
is like, hey, I don't
want to have cloud sprawl.
I don't want every group
to have their own account,
and they're spinning up how
many different resources,
and their billing is
getting out of control,
and I'm going to lose control.
As an IT advocate, everything
eventually falls on me.
So an organization node allows
you to have that top level
visibility of all
the projects that
are below that organization.
So you never have
to feel like, hey, I
don't know what's going on
inside of my environment,
and who's doing what,
who has access to what.
And this applies
to policies, too.
So you can apply a policy
at the organization node
and have it trickle down.
And it'll trickle down,
essentially, to projects.
Projects are essentially
containers for everything
that represents anything
under that project.
And so, you can think of
it like, hey, we want--
you could do it by dev test,
QA, integrity, production,
et cetera, or you can
do it by application.
CRM is in this project
or so on and so forth.
And a lot of times
it's a mix and match.
You have projects by purpose
and projects by function.
But you can do some other
things with projects as well.
You can install
SSH keys centrally.
So if you're like,
hey, this project
is going to be for
this development effort
and these developers
need access to it,
you can put in everybody's
SSH key into that public key
into that project and
it'll be propagated
through into the environment
for anybody to use those VMs.
You invite people to projects,
which is kind of cool.
So you don't have to
statically provision them.
You can literally say I
want to invite this person
by their email address.
They're associated with
the billing account.
So you can have
multiple accounts--
multiple projects associated
with the billing account.
And so, I get asked how would
you recommend straightening out
projects?
And I say do both.
Have projects that are based on
our environment and function--
like, again, CRM or customer
service, dev test, broad QA,
et cetera.
But give developers a project.
Projects don't cost anything.
And so, you can have a bunch
of projects all associated
with the same billing account.
Nothing ramps up cloud know-how.
If you think back to my
first-- one of the first slides
was [INAUDIBLE] how
do I accelerate this?
What are the skills
that I need for this?
Give everybody a sandbox.
You can set billing
alarms so you
know when somebody is getting
crazy, but give them a sandbox.
Give them a target in
terms of how quickly you
want something turned over.
There was something
a while ago that
started to go out
of fashion, which
was internal hack-a-thons, and
challenging your developers
and your IT folks
to deliver something
within a certain
timed box activity.
So what I found
accelerates the best
is when you give every
developer their own project.
At the end of the day,
if they don't use it,
it's just sitting there.
It doesn't cost you anything.
But that's what I've seen
help accelerate cloud usage.
And the developer projects,
keep those isolated.
So folks are like, oh, I don't
know what they're going to do.
Are they going to mess around?
There's more risk to some
developer going rogue
within the environment
and accidentally
running a DHCP server
or some nefarious server
without knowing it,
inside your environment.
And that has a huge
blast radius impact.
When you create a project from
a Google Cloud perspective
and you give every
developer their own project,
well, if they go haywire
and do something crazy,
it's not connected back
to your home environment.
So it's a nice,
safe way to instill
or to instigate moving forward.
Networking-- so
moving down the list.
This is one where if
you don't get it right,
it can be so painful, because
people have deployed VMs,
and they've deployed
applications.
And then you take it to
networking and networking
is like, thank you
for using 10.1.1.1.
That's what our company uses.
You can't use this, and
you have this conflict.
And how do you deal with it?
So a couple of ways to deal with
it-- one, involve networking
early, but two, start
with automation.
Try and not, as
much as possible,
to craft things by hand.
Automate using whatever
popular tool suite
you have, but automate
this from the beginning.
So I only mentioned
networking on its own,
because this is where I see
a lot of folks when it starts
to go to production, and they
get the network folks involved,
and they want to
talk about firewalls.
The first reaction
is like, oh, you've
totally clobbered our
internal IP space.
You can't launch with this.
So some things here to realize
is that, if you notice,
we have different
regions, et cetera.
I think that's pretty familiar.
We have different zones.
But if you notice the subnets,
they go between regions--
or you go between
this whole network.
And you notice that you
have subnets in one region
and subnets in another region.
And it looks like there's
a backbone connecting them.
That's because there is.
So you can have a subnetwork
that spans zones, and you
can have a subnetwork that looks
in a totally different region.
And it's like as if
you, as a company,
created a data center
in one, geography
in a data center in
another, geography
are a different continent.
And you're like, hey, if we were
to create our own data centers,
we'd put some VPN,
or MPLS, et cetera.
And we'd expect native
connectivity between VMs in one
and VMs in the other.
That's given to you natively.
That's on Google's
backbone, Google's network.
You have private addressing
with no VPN end-to-end
between all your
different regions
and in the same project
in the same network.
And that's probably different
than what we're used to.
And so, what is that
global backbone?
What is that global scope?
I mean, this is
a current picture
of current and
committed regions,
points of presence, et cetera.
But that's a nice
feature, is you're
taking our fiber under
the ocean when you-- let's
say you had an Asia deployment,
and a European deployment,
and a US deployment.
All that's riding across
a private network.
Moving, again, onto the
DevOps side of the house,
I just talked a minute
ago about automation.
Yes, containers are a thing.
What do they solve?
They solve packaging.
Containers solve packaging.
They solve, basically, the
ability to bundle things
up in a consistent way,
that's consistently
executable in a
different environment,
no matter how they're
deployed onto a host.
So check positive
for awesomeness.
Google has-- from a Linux
kernel perspective--
Google's contributed
a number of things
to Linux kernel that's
made containers possible.
But from Google's own lessons--
in terms of how they run
packages and internally on
something we call board--
containers are just
one side of the story.
How you orchestrate
and deploy containers
is a whole different ballgame.
How do you schedule
jobs, and how do you
ensure that jobs have continuity
when they've been interrupted,
et cetera?
That's where things
get interesting.
So there's a number of talks
today about Kubernetes--
or over the next three days
about Kubernetes and the Google
Container Engine that I
encourage you to talk to--
or, I'm sorry, go attend there
and talk to the presenters
there.
But all of Google's
experience, what
they've learned out of Borg
has been put into Kubernetes.
And it's an open sourced
project in the wild.
So one thing I'd mention
there, I talked a second ago
about the networking.
And it's like, hey, the best way
to ensure that you don't shoot
yourself in the foot when
it comes to networking
is to automate from the start.
And if you had to choose between
automating or the new hotness--
which is what containers are--
choose automation.
You'll get a lot more
bang for your buck
about how to automate
different processes more
so than containers.
Once you've figured
out automation,
absolutely, go for
containers, go for Kubernetes,
but don't go the
other way around.
Try as much as you can not to
build things by hand or deploy
things by hand.
The other thing about
containers that's interesting
is that you may find yourself
challenging conventional ways
to do things.
If you think about
conventional host deployments,
you deploy something.
And in a traditional
environment you
may, hey, let's
prime down anti-virus
and all these bolt
on tools that you
do, because of the
mentality of this
being an everlasting
infrastructure that could
get compromised at any time.
Container sort of
changes that model
or puts it on its head where
you would say, OK, well,
I need to do things like
vulnerability scanning
and security measurement as
part of my build process,
because I'm creating
immutable images.
And so, it doesn't really--
there are new
techniques, in terms
of probes and things
like that, to discover
when your environment
is going haywire.
But challenge the
traditional way
that you may be dealing with
enterprise environments, where
you lay down anti-virus and you
lay down all sorts of tools.
Instead, you can
say, we've made sure
that this immutable
artifact, this container
is secure by part of
our build process,
and so, the output is secure.
Now, if something
happens, you simply
spin out a new container.
Don't over-engineer
the platform.
An example of this is--
our discs are already
heavily replicated
in HA behind the scenes.
So you don't need to create a
VM and then create two discs,
and say, well, I've got to
RAID these two together,
and then event one fails.
We're already taking care of
all that replication for you
behind the scenes.
Similarly, if you're using
Google Cloud Storage or object
storage, we're already making
a number of copies of that.
So you don't have to say,
well, let me put one copy here.
Let me create another
bucket called backup copy.
That's already handled
for you behind the scenes.
Similarly, we have a
product called Stackdriver,
which facilitates logging.
So if you're going to have an
entire logging infrastructure,
realize there's actually a very
simple to use API that's part
and parcel to every part
of your-- every project,
that you can simply
just say send
my logging into Stackdriver
and you get that.
And there's a bunch
of other things.
There's a built-in load balance.
There's load balancers.
There's tracing.
You can actually do code
tracing, instance mitigation.
There's things that
we provide in terms
that we call live migration.
So if you're inside
of a zone and a VM
needs to be taken
down for maintenance,
we live migrate that
VM to another VM
so that you don't suffer
the consequence of us
having to do maintenance.
Similarly, if you're running--
if you have data that's stored
on AWS, on S3, and you're like,
hey, I'd like to use
Google as a backup
or I'd like to use some of the
data analytics tool on Google,
we have a transfer service.
You don't have to write
your own transfer service
or run a MapReduce job.
You can literally go inside
of our object storage
and say transfer service,
and then move that data over.
And I have a lot
of customers that
are doing that on
a regular basis,
because they use Google
for data processing.
This is a huge, huge advantage
that a number of customers
have mentioned.
This has really changed
the way they approach
solving data science problems.
Going back to the Hadoop
discussion earlier,
you tend to have
a Hadoop cluster.
And what I've heard from
a number of customers--
specifically in
[? adtech-- ?] is
that Hadoop cluster
starts to get really,
really bogged down
with recurring jobs.
Essentially, you have to figure
out how to batch jobs together.
It doesn't really encourage
a lot of data exploration.
You're kind of stuck where a
lot of data scientists and data
professionals are
spending more time
managing their cluster than
they are doing data science.
BigQuery is like renting
thousands of cores for seconds.
You submit a job, it distributes
that job to thousands of cores,
and you get answers back,
usually in seconds to minutes.
And we've heard stories of folks
going from literally like, hey,
we used to run
this 19 hour report
and now we're down
to like 20 minutes.
And so, if you're going to
take anything else away,
figure out how you
can leverage BigQuery.
And when you're in
BigQuery, everything
looks like a BigQuery
problem, including ETL
and including other things.
For those processes that
don't lend themselves
to go into BigQuery yet,
we have other things
like a published subsystem
for events and whatnot.
But if you're really stuck
and it's like no, no, I've
got processes that are
built around Hadoop,
then go back to the model
I talked about earlier.
We have cloud data proc.
So you can get a full Hadoop
cluster in 90 seconds.
And so, you can schedule
Hadoop jobs, MapReduce jobs
against your data as
individual pieces of work,
where you could have that
data sitting inside of GCS.
And then when it's
time to process,
you kick off a cluster
[? via an API call, ?] process
it, and then pull it back.
The way that I hear
the BigQuery story told
is when customers describe it
as democratizing data access.
Because all of a sudden now
all his data scientists--
or all their data scientists
were able to get at data
and start running
ad hoc queries.
And he's like, that unlocked
so much more value for us.
And they
[? are an adtech ?] company.
And so, being able
to start figuring out
better segmentation and
running queries that just never
were possible before made a
big change to their business.
So I'll finish with this is that
you've heard a lot about how
Google treats data.
And that's because data is this
constant, virtuous cycle, where
we see as customers can get
more and more in their data--
and we've seen this
time and time again
with folks using BigQuery
and our ML products,
is that they spend a lot of
time taking care of their data.
Because now they
can put it in GCS,
and they can store forever, and
they can put it in BigQuery,
and they can start running
queries and they never did.
All of a sudden,
they're able to start
deriving new business patterns.
And that gives them insights,
and that turns around
and plugs them right
back into innovation.
It's thinking of new
products they can do,
because they've got access and
insights from data they never
had before.
And once they've done
that, all of a sudden
they're able to
craft new software.
New software leads to more data.
And so, it's this constant cycle
of a faster iteration cycle,
and richer and better software.
And there's a bunch
of talks on ML.
So I would suggest
attending one of those
to figure out what
the tweak is that ML
is putting on the data spin.
And with that, thank you.